lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
responder a una pregunta muy antigua y
que a mí me parece muy interesante esta
pregunta es si yo tuviera un precipicio
aquí o no sé a lo mejor este es algún
edificio que tiene una altura h tiene
una altura h aquí
y la pregunta es si yo estuviera aquí
arriba aquí estoy yo si yo fuera a
saltar aunque bueno no es más
recomendable al menos para alturas muy
grandes o si yo fuera a tirar algo no sé
quizás una roca por este precipicio qué
tan rápido ya sea yo o esta roca iríamos
justo antes de dar contra el suelo y
como en todos los otros vídeos que hemos
estado haciendo sobre movimiento de
proyectiles vamos a ignorar la
resistencia al aire lo cual es válido
para alturas pequeñas y también para
velocidades pequeñas o también si el
objeto es muy aerodinámico y si también
es denso la resistencia al aire no va a
influir mucho si fuera yo aventarme de
panza desde una altura grande entonces
ahí si la resistencia del aire tendría
mucha influencia pero para mantener esto
simple vamos a suponer que no hay aire
para no tener que tomar en cuenta los
efectos de la resistencia al aire
podríamos suponer que estamos haciendo
esto en un planeta parecido a la tierra
pero que no tiene aire pensemos en el
problema y algunos de ustedes podrían
comentarme oye es que esto no es
realista bueno eso sería realista para
una altura pequeña para una noche
pequeña
si yo saltara del techo de un edificio
de un piso no tendría resistencia al
aire la resistencia del aire no sería un
componente grande que afecte la
velocidad si fuera de un edificio mucho
más alto entonces ahí sí ya podría
afectar mi velocidad aunque claro yo no
os recomiendo que hagan ninguna de estas
cosas todo esto es muy peligroso así que
mejor hagámoslo con la piedra pensamos
un poco en esto oculto cuando estoy
lanzando la piedra
tendremos una velocidad inicial de cero
y aquí nuevamente vamos a usar la
convención de que las cantidades
positivas o las velocidades positivas
indican el sentido hacia arriba o un
vector positivo significa que va hacia
arriba y un vector negativo indica que
va hacia abajo su dirección así que aquí
tenemos una velocidad inicial de cero y
aquí el fondo vamos a tener una
velocidad final que no conozca ahorita y
que va a ser una cantidad negativa
porque la dirección de este vector
velocidad final va a ser hacia abajo así
que esto va a ser negativo
y sabemos que la aceleración de la
gravedad de un objeto en caída libre y
que está cercano a la superficie de la
tierra y vamos a suponer que es
constante nuestra aceleración constante
va a ser igual a menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado lo que vamos a hacer
es teniendo en altura y teniendo a
nuestra velocidad inicial igual a cero y
nuestra aceleración constante igual a
menos 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
queremos encontrar cuál es la velocidad
final justo antes de dar contra el suelo
supongamos que está h está dada en
metros y tendremos un resultado de
metros por segundo para esta velocidad
final
veamos cómo podemos encontrarla sabemos
cosas básicas y el propósito de esto es
mostrarles que ustedes siempre pueden
inferir las fórmulas a partir de cosas
muy básicas que conocemos sabemos que el
desplazamiento es igual a la velocidad
promedio
x el cambio en el tiempo
y sabemos también que la velocidad
promedio siempre y cuando supongamos que
la aceleración es constante que es lo
que estamos haciendo acá la velocidad
promedio va a ser la velocidad final más
la velocidad inicial entre 2 y también
sabemos que nuestro cambio en el tiempo
la cantidad de tiempo que transcurre
esto va a ser igual a nuestro cambio en
la velocidad dividida entre nuestra
aceleración y sólo para asegurarnos que
comprendemos esto esto viene de la idea
de que la aceleración o vamos a
escribirlo de esta manera que el cambio
en velocidad es igual a la aceleración
por el tiempo o mejor dicho la
aceleración por el cambio en el tiempo
así que si dividimos ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre la aceleración nos va a
quedar esto el cambio en el tiempo es
igual al cambio en la velocidad entre la
aceleración y todo esto es nuestro
desplazamiento y aquí tenemos la fórmula
del desplazamiento en términos de cosas
que conocemos y de la cosa que queremos
encontrar la velocidad final para este
ejemplo de acá vamos a escribir lo que
sabemos y vamos a hacer lo paso por paso
sabemos que nuestra velocidad inicial es
igual a cero así que esta primera
expresión para el ejemplo que estamos
viendo nuestra velocidad promedio va a
ser la velocidad final entre dos ya que
nuestra velocidad inicial es de share y
nuestro cambio en velocidad es igual a
la velocidad final menos la velocidad
inicial esta es la diferencia en las
velocidades y aquí nuevamente sabemos
que la velocidad inicial es cero por lo
que nuestro cambio en la velocidad es
igual a la velocidad final esto va a
estar multiplicado por nuestra velocidad
final entre la aceleración la velocidad
final es igual al cambio en la velocidad
porque vimos que el cambio en la
velocidad es igual a la velocidad final
menos
inicial pero nuestra velocidad inicial
es ser por lo que queda que es igual a
la velocidad final y todo esto es igual
a nuestro desplazamiento y ahora si
tenemos esto expresado en cosas que
conocemos si multiplicaremos ambos lados
de esta igualdad por 2 por la
aceleración aquí escribo 2 por la
aceleración de este lado y escribo lo
mismo de este otro lado 2 por la
aceleración en el lado izquierdo nos
quedaría 2 por la aceleración por el
desplazamiento y esto va a ser igual a
lo que tenemos del lado derecho este 2
se cancela con este otro 2 esta
aceleración se cancela con esta otra
aceleración y nos queda velocidad final
al cuadrado así que eso es igual a
velocidad final al cuadrado y ahora
podemos despejar nuestra velocidad final
sabemos que nuestra aceleración es menos
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado vamos
a sustituirlo acá así que tenemos 2 x
hacemos la multiplicación 2 por menos
9.8 es igual a menos 19 puntos 6 metros
por segundo al cuadrado
y aquí cuál es nuestro desplazamiento
cuál es el desplazamiento de esta roca
en movimiento una vez que la tiramos por
el precipicio por el edificio estaríamos
tentados a decir que nuestro
desplazamiento es h pero recuerden que
estas son cantidades vectoriales tenemos
que indicar la dirección del
desplazamiento en este caso y si vemos
en donde comenzó la roca y en donde
terminó sus direcciones hacia abajo y
usando nuestra convención va a ser una
cantidad negativa para indicar esta
dirección así que en este caso nuestro
desplazamiento para esta roca desde que
deja nuestra mano hasta que toca el
suelo va a ser igual a menos h va a
recorrer una distancia de h pero con la
dirección hacia abajo es por eso que
escribimos este vector como negativo así
que nuestro desplazamiento aquí va a ser
menos h menos h metros
recordamos que esta h va a estar
expresada en metros así que cuando
multiplicamos estas dos cosas
afortunadamente para nosotros estos dos
negativos se cancelan y nos queda 19.6
por h
metros cuadrados en tres segundos
cuadrados
y esto va a ser igual a nuestra
velocidad final al cuadrado y recuerden
que cuando elevamos al cuadrado perdemos
el signo que pudo haber tenido esta
cantidad si nuestra velocidad final
fuera positiva al elevarla al cuadrado
queda positiva pero si fuera negativa al
elevarlo al cuadrado va a quedar
positiva pero recordemos que en este
ejemplo nuestra velocidad final va a ser
negativa porque la dirección va a ser
hacia abajo así que queremos la versión
negativa de esto así que para encontrar
nuestra velocidad final vamos a tomar la
raíz cuadrada negativa en ambos lados de
esta igualdad así que si sacamos la raíz
cuadrada en ambos lados vamos a tener y
aquí los voy a invertir tendremos que
nuestra velocidad final es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 19.6 por h y si sacamos
la raíz cuadrada de metros cuadrados
entre segundos cuadrados que podemos
tratarlas como variables aunque sean
unidades y las ponemos aquí fuera de
esta raíz cuadrada nos quedarán metros
por segundo lo que está bien ya que son
las unidades de la velocidad y aquí
tenemos que tener cuidado de que si
estamos sacando la raíz principal de
aquí pero sabe
que nuestra velocidad final va a ser
negativa pues queremos asegurarnos de
que tengamos aquí una cantidad negativa
que nuestra raíz cuadrada sea negativa
ahora usemos algunos números para
calcular esto pues aquí ya tenemos cuál
es la fórmula para encontrar la
velocidad final que es lo que queríamos
para saber qué tan rápido vamos cayendo
como una función de la altura así que
ahora probemos con algunos números para
ver qué nos da digamos que la altura es
de cinco metros que esto podría ser si
tiramos una roca desde lo alto de un
edificio de un piso a lo mejor de un
edificio comercial de un piso que tendrá
aproximadamente esta altura de cinco
metros sacamos nuestra calculadora
limpiamos esto y que vamos a obtener si
ponemos cinco metros acá entonces vamos
a multiplicar 19.6 por cinco y nos va a
dar como resultado 98 casi 100 y ahora
obtenemos la raíz cuadrada de esto que
va a ser casi 10
a 9.89 de 94 que podamos redondear a 9.9
y no olvidemos que tenemos que tomar la
raíz cuadrada negativa así que en esa
situación cuando nuestra altura es de 5
metros si lanzamos algo desde lo alto de
un edificio comercial de un piso cuando
este objeto esté por tocar el suelo va a
tener una velocidad final de menos 9.9
metros por segundo y les dejaré a
ustedes como ejercicio encontrar esta
cantidad pero expresada en kilómetros
por hora aunque les puedo decir que esta
velocidad es bastante rápida y de hecho
no es algo que ustedes quieran hacer y
con esto podemos calcular la velocidad
final sin importar la altura siempre y
cuando ésta sea razonablemente cercana a
la superficie de la tierra y no tomamos
en cuenta los efectos de la resistencia
al aire para alturas muy grandes y
especialmente si el objeto no es
aerodinámico entonces la resistencia al
aire va a jugar un papel muy importante